I'm about to have a kid that I have to
keep alive and take care of and love and
and teach right from wrong and different
things like that so there's there's way
too much stuff my I remember my dad
looked at me he's like one day I was a
little bummed out like depressed he's
like Anthony you don't have time to be
depressed anymore you better pick this
up you know that's what I wanted to ask
you are there things you've already
asked your dad about just like I used to
cry to my dad in college that I was like
I don't know if anyone's ever gonna love
me
um like because I'm blind on I'll never
be able to have a family no one will
ever want to have a kid with me like
that was some of my biggest fears in
life and he's like son yeah you're a
fetish
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
foreign
[Music]